no um a couple of of uh declarations um
on item four uh the um self-build and uh
costom build I chaired the working group
on that um I I approach it with with an
open mind although I obviously have a
background in that uh also on item nine
uh the um Community infrastructure Levy
there's a couple items there uh I am the
vice chairman of the St wolston punch uh
group
uh who and I see that uh group has has
got a bid in uh I don't think we make
any decisions on that today so it's I
think that's probably okay I'll take
advice on that and also uh with the
counselor Crump and councelor padum uh
we submitted a a bid for the um s to
napton cycle track and again I don't
think we're Tak any decision on that but
I'll take advice on how we should
proceed thank you chairman
councel c um similar to you uh chair I'm
also a um a trustee of act on energy if
necessary for item seven and on item 10
I have a pecuniary interest and I will
be leaving the meeting for that uh for
that item councelor
G um just item 10 I helped uh feny
Compton Parish Council uh write their
bit and Marcia Eon head of Law and
governance do you want to come in at
this this point yes chair just to say
that regarding Declarations of Interest
today if there are Declarations of
Interest where they're declaring an
interest and it's not pecuniary and they
are not prejudicial then it's absolutely
fine to stay in so long as they're not
predetermined uh with with one exception
none of them are are pecuniary or
prejudicial I think it's only the one
that is and that and that has been noted
thank you very much indeed uh and um
we're moving on now to minutes um the
minutes of the last meeting um that have
you all read them and if so are you
happy for them to be uh for them to be
signed off or have you got any questions
that you want to raise on them no all
happy thank you can I have the
recommendations on that and smoo on to
accept them George coun councel CER and
councelor G thank
you
the next item is um planning Economic
Development portfolio the introduction
of the self-build and custom house
building register fee and this is
councelor coucher to move uh to outline
and then to move the
recommendations thank you chair thank
you for that um this is a important
matter um that uh I know
um has been considered by the council
for quite a long period of time and
indeed Nigel Rock chaired The Working
party in relation to that um we're now
crystallizing I think the policy um here
um in paragraph 1.2 you have some of the
um benefits of Uh custom and self-build
um I would also want to highlight to you
also some of the dis benefits of them
and particularly the fact that uh um
applications under this heading do not
contribute to infrastructure costs and
to sill and secondly frankly in some
areas um where permissions have been
granted it's undermined uh neighborhood
plans um which I think is not good for
local
communities uh there is a need I think
to get um this uh Arrangement under
control our existing registration scheme
at the moment has people who registered
going back as far as
2016 um and we also we need to make sure
that they are genuinely people who are
interested in uh actually acting and and
building a a house in in in our district
and so therefore a a financial charge is
very very important um you will see I
think in the report that many other
districts um in our general area do
charge for this um up until now it's
been free in in Stratford District um
and we are introducing a charge um to
make sure that we are genuinely seeing
people who are genuinely interested in
this particular activity uh charge a £95
to be registered on it um the officer's
report I think is for um a renewal
charge of only 25 which seems a little
low on my from my point of view but
we'll um I think the most important
thing is actually getting the register
uh started um which is very very
important this is going to establish
frankly the demand for this type of
housing and is very important when we're
considering the South arer local plan
going forward thank you sorry and I move
the
recommendations councelor rock thank you
chairman um I like George I very much
welcome the progress that we've made on
here I think the
uh this is as George has said I I
chaired the working group on that and
I'm pleased to see we're moving forward
um I I would I would still like to see
uh a part one and part two register um
and I see we we're not going to do that
um um but I think the data that would
fall within it we're still going to be
able to recognize that so I'll go along
with this for the for the trial period
uh I I I I do believe that the we've
been losing money on this basically
because we we've we've had to start this
up there's been quite a lot of demand
activity uh in our district in
particular on this and we need we need
we do need to cover those costs
um well we can see but I mean the 25
renewal I'm sure the finance team not
sure we can issue an invoice for
£25 and cover our cost but again we we
can see um the register is the primary
source of evidence for the demand um
having read through the responses
um I can see we're responding to the
consultation which of course we should
do we should take that into account but
I do think some of the respondents have
possibly misunderstood the purpose of
the um the register which is to assess
overall demand rather than pre Prejudice
any particular planning application or
any particular individual
self-builder uh however um I I'll
support the recommendations uh and we'll
see how that goes and see how that um
improves and cleans up the uh the
evidence base and and so I I welcome the
uh implementations which are all based
on the um the work of the task and
finish group and I see the chairman of
uh of over scrutiny is about to speak
but I know he very much assisted our
work on that that group during last year
thank you chairman and the chairman of
OV and scrutiny Community um I think
this was was this discussed at over and
scrutiny
very briefly um we obviously we' got a
pack to dender on this one but we did
discuss briefly and I did have a
slightly informal um meeting with one of
your one of the members happens to be
one of your group as well um so um am I
is okay if I um brief some you'll be I'm
not surprised to know that Council
rocker and I are very similar on this we
obviously both on the on the working
party and spent a lot of time on this um
I welcome the fact there's going to be a
fee to look at um potentially thin out
the number of applications or entries on
the on the combined register um but is
there any way that they that register
with over 300es on could be thinned out
anyway is there another Pro process of
procedure um because it does seem a lot
and does seem
unwieldy um and if some of those go back
to
2016 um you know 7 years ago you know
coming up to coming up to wa potentially
are they still valid are those people
still around and you know it's just
comment really but I do welcome the fact
there's going to be a
charge
consultation um obviously not I think it
said 91 individuals on the district and
six on
outside um with the disagreement of
introduction of a part two
this I like Council of rock I would like
to see a part two um
of the on the list and I think other
local authorities are doing that um we s
the consultation of
91 um and they were opposed of it but
sometimes you just wonder whe people
it's like asking turkeys to vote for
Christmas potentially on this one
so that might be an item you know again
it might have been not an issue but
that's the comment I've received so um
so I think I'll pass it on um so again I
you know we would I would potentially
like the part two register and and the
final Point again they seem to be agree
with Council Rock in a lots of times
today um the 225 for the renewal I don't
think that is cost effective um and
covers all lot cost I might be wrong um
but 25 doesn't seem seem a lot so um so
just some thoughts and comments and
generally on the whole pleased with its
introduction the working party task and
finish group um worked hard on that um
and we can see the
benefits but it might want to go just a
little bit further potentially thank you
um Council C would you like to come back
on those comments yes I mean obviously
this is going to be a new register so
all of those historic people frankly we
we removed the Old Register will be will
be filed um if you want to be on this
register you'll need to pay the fee and
obviously it'll be only people that pay
the fees that will be on it so I think
that will I'm sure thin out and and get
rid of uh the
um speculative people who've just just
wanted to be there um I think the second
point in relation to the parts who
register we will be asking for
information about where people do live
live at the moment so I suspect that
we're going to be able to extract the
information that we would get out on on
on a part to in in terms of how we're
doing because we can ask whatever
questions we want um in relation to
applicants um so so I think uh I think
I'm less concerned the fact that we're
just going for a single register I think
we'll still be able to to get that
evidence out if we need to to
demonstrate if there's a geographical
locality which which people are
particularly interested in and and where
people are coming from as to as to why
they're doing that um you had one other
question which which I've the renewal
cost of25 and the renewal cost of 25
well I share your view and I think
frankly chair I think we should review
that to see whether whether that is the
right figure or whether we should be
looking for something uh something
higher for that I I think the most
important thing at the moment is to
actually get the register up and running
that's the that's the most critical
thing get it up and running uh in uh in
this year uh and then um get people onto
the register with the initial um charge
and then we can look at the um the
renewal uh as people come up um
councelor Sarah W
hoggins thank you um I just to say that
uh I welcome this pie from the combined
working party coming to the FL here but
the question that I've got really and it
may be for offices to answer this as
well is that um if applications come to
the four how much weight is going to be
given to those who have been registered
on the list for wanting self bills for
some time is what I'm concerned about is
the defacto pseudo developers that are
suddenly bringing and we know this it's
happened uh in two of two the council
ass on this table today have got
experience of this they bring forward a
plot of or a parcel of land for say 10
12 17 allegedly self-build houses uh
permission is then granted because we
haven't given enough uh permissions for
self-build houses and I wonder if we can
give any weight to them having to
demonstrate that people within the list
have expressed a lit um an interest in
having a self-build in that area I
suppose what I'm trying to do is to
guard against what I would say um was
um speculative and also um profiteering
and you know because by their very
essence of self-build it is regarded as
s for some a cheaper option of owning
your own house and we mustn't we mustn't
forget that either thank you for that
yeah I'll bring in councel coucher
because I certainly recognize that
scenario from a couple of years ago
I think um that's the whole purpose of
what we're trying to do here is is to
try and bring some order in into into
this situation because at the moment
people can just register their interest
and uh and go onto it now at least there
will be a financial hurdle to get over
before you do that uh clearly we will be
both registering where people would want
to build their self-build housing um uh
so uh and um obviously registering the
date of registration as well which I
think will also be be be relevant if we
get a whole load of of of applications
immediately before a planning
application came in um I think that may
have less weight than than if there is a
historic historic uh um registration um
to demonstrate genuine um wish uh to to
uh to do this type of act to do this
type of activity I think what we're
doing here is hopefully tightening
things up I think we will learn from
experience as to whether this is correct
whether we need to review it again or
not will be a matter that I think we'll
remain open
to coun W hugin do you want to come back
in again yeah and just to follow on from
that it's also the S the still aspect of
the of of this of this as well because
when a developer or a land owner comes
forward and bring brings the the land to
the FL if you're having 10 11 17 houses
self build there I believe that it's a
very different ball game with regards to
sill payments than perhaps an individual
plot of land but um I'm wondering what
um overtures the planning department is
actually making with regards to uh s
payments and levies being required for
this because you know Mass builds of
self build houses has a tremendous
effect particularly on the smaller
Villages I'm looking at uh councelor
Curtis here who's looking back at me
because we both know exactly the types
of and size of developments that coming
coming through which will have a major
impact on Village Life and for which
uh the the parish council would be
receiving nothing it might be useful to
bring in the C the planning offers at
the at this moment because this we are
dealing with national legislation that
came in some years ago and that you
might be able to clarify that with us uh
thank you leader well I was just going
to make that point actually that yeah we
do operate within the uh legislative
framework of the self-build ACT uh
There's no distinction between self
build and custom build in that in the
act so in in many respects our hands are
tied by how we can um manage self-build
the the purpose of the um the the fee is
to cover our costs of managing that and
the benefits of an enhanced service are
set out in par
1.17 uh so we are looking to have a
dedicated resource to assist with this
um and that's the the primary driver for
introducing the fee is to say it's
costing this Council x uh the fee will
help us cover that um that cost the
other point to note is uh recommendation
three uh which the point you made leader
uh my my advice is introduce the fee now
and then review and monitor uh how it's
operating and we can reflect and see if
we want to to update in due course by my
advice is let's put the fee in uh and um
restart register and um run the service
as as we should do thank you thank you
very much I think we've had a good
discussion on that one um we do need a
second or um councilor Rock are you
going to Second this yes just about to
say I'll second the recommendation I was
going to make all the points that have
been made are all well made and I think
we're all in agreement with that uh I
think uh uh Mr Kord has made all the
points some of the other points that we
made uh the port hard myself and discuss
some of those other points because it's
close to my heart having chaired that
working group some of these other points
we will we try and work within the
legislations we can to try and tidy up
some of these Loose Ends uh point three
makes that point we want to keep it
under review so I'm going to Second
these
recommendations um and uh I'll over to
you chair um the rest of the cabinet uh
are you happy with that those
recommendations are we happy to move
them okay thank you all accept
the next item is um the Strategic risk
register and this comes under my
portfolio um 1.2 outlines the um
particular concern that has raised this
um the Strategic risk register should be
reviewed quarterly by the council's
management tweet team which it has is
and then twice a year by the council's
cabinet but the Strategic risk register
has not been reviewed by by by the
cabinet for a number of years so this
document will now be updated and
reported on regularly in future and
that's basically um the the actions that
are in the recommendation so does
anybody want to uh add anything to that
recommendation uh I've got now uh the
chief executive who wants to come in at
that point chairman I need to apologize
and I'm sorry for the sloppy drafting on
on on on the the report on the paragraph
1.2 cabinet did consider the FIS
register in in March
this year it's true in March it hadn't
been considered for a number of years so
I apologize that that I I didn't pick
that up in in the draft and the report
apologies so so recommend um recognizing
that it was done though there had been a
gap um so I do take that in board
councelor Wally Huggins yes um I'm
really I'm a little bit curious as to
why this has come about really because
uh this is really serious it's very
important that it does happen and it
does I believe rest with the chief
executive really as to why this has not
been happening on the regular basis and
how we ensure that this um slippage
doesn't occur again as is there an
officer now that is tasked with
completing this on a regular basis and
bring it for for review for example
which you're overseeing I'm sure now Mr
B thank you uh I would make sure that it
is a regular feature because it is
absolutely key that we do address the
risks um that uh come to the council we
have seen across the country a number of
councils that have um not been as strict
on their uh risk requirements as others
we we are have to be make sure that we
are completely up to date on uh
recognizing any risk to this Council and
councelor rock and then u councelor w
hoggins do you want to come in first
councelor W yeah how did this slip it
occur I'm I'm concerned to know really
it was a previous administration so I
don't know but the chief executive can
probably fill you in chairman thank you
and and and and you right absolutely
correct that we should have been
bringing in the register more regularly
than we have it has been an
extraordinary busy period for the
council with the challenges from Co and
also discussions of the merger we we
have Arrangements in place through
balire County Council to help us
regularly review the risk register
and I can assure you it was undertaken
at management team but hadn't come
forward to the to the cabinet so that
was an error on my behalf and I'll make
sure that doesn't happen
again and councelor rock uh thank you
very much I was quite interested to read
this in in a previous life I was charged
with the responsibility of risk
management in a couple of companies
where I worked
um just an observation it would appear
that the the the risk Matrix has been
done by service or areas of
activity and there doesn't seem to be a
sort of cross-service um Arrangement so
for instance when I look at the the
impact
measures at the top of the list we've
got a fatality is the absolutely worst
thing that can happen
um yet we it's not normalized it's well
is normalized so the level of
risk uh in a particular
service seems constant across the
services if you know what I mean whereas
we don't look at the risk in total to
the to the
organization uh I'm just wondering it in
in future I'm not suggest we do it now
but is that something we we might look
at um instead of doing it one by one and
saying they're all the same level
clearly some things might be more
serious than others
um have I explained that proper exective
happy to look at that Council Ro what
what what we trying to do is is provide
some guidance to make the assessment
under the likelihood and the impact of
of course the higher the likelihood the
higher the impact the more serious issue
it is to the authority what what we have
attempted to do Under the reg itself is
nominate a lead officer for each of
those risks that doesn't mean to say
that they're just owned by that one team
they are corporate risks affecting the
authority but to ensure that we have a
set of actions that can address those
issues that's why we've we've laid it at
the responsibility of a a single head of
service um but more than happy to to
consider the future there has been sub
years since we've we've rev viwed the
likelihood and impact um methodology and
it's in line with the current risk uh
risk management strategy but but I'm
happy to look at that if I can just come
back chairman not tend to be a criticism
more of a suggestion to uh what might
considered thank you and I've got um
councelor and councelor Crump and then
councelor CES just hopefully it might be
a helpful suggestion whether we we can
bring this to OS seat and again take on
councelor Rock's point about the
methodology um and that way if it's if
it's in several areas hopefully there's
less chance of it being missed so
hopefully that's a helpful
suggestion um yes I'm sure that's um I
don't think it was discusted over essay
but that you might want to take that one
back to them and councelor Curtis thank
you leader um just a very specific thing
on page 55 the impact of cyber threat I
had an extreme helpful briefing from the
IT team on this and I perhaps suggest
that an action could be added to this
that a regular briefing or fairly
regular briefings to all members from
the IT team on potential risks and how
to avoid them might be a useful addition
thank
you any more comments if not I will move
the recommendation uh I look for a
second Council of coost and uh are we
all happy to accept that recommendation
those recommendations okay accepted
thank
you next item is councelor calls um
which is the uh approval of procurement
temporary accommodation contract for
discharge of homeless n duties and
Powers if you'd like to kind of
summarize and just say something about
the recommendation thank you thank you
leader uh approval of this is
essentially app approval of procurement
for temporary accommodation uh it is um
um a service already in existence to
help the district council for it
statutory and our discretionary
responsibilities to the homeless the
recommendations are that we Grant
permission to procure the temporary
accommodation contract for the purpose
of fulfilling those requirements those
that we required under legislation those
that we choose to do ourselves um that
we give permission to reward a temporary
accommodation contract based on the eval
valuation of Tenders in other words we
put in place the structure to Tender for
the service and that we award the
contract award decision be delegated to
the head of
housing um obviously there is a great
deal of information in here but we are
essentially looking for uh permission to
put in place the process to ensure that
we're getting the best service for the
best price for the best outcome for our
residents and those affected by the
contract
and and it comes to a time obviously
When U there is uncertainty um I know
that there is the impact of the renters
Reform Bill for example so we do need to
be sure that we've got um these kind of
um these kind of this kind of
procurement U process in in place so are
you moving the recommendations on that
okay anybody got a question on it before
we go to a second and a vote councelor
Crump um as you know we we discussed
this in quite detail on on Friday over
see and I think we gave uh I think we
were quite kind and gentle with Council
Co which uh I think she appreciate it
but I think went through several things
on this one um we were consider well we
wanted to raise the fact that um the
officers weren't able to rise on the
performance of of the contractor at the
meeting um but we were ass sure there
would be an assessment process as part
of the procurement and we felt it was
important for lessons learned from the
previous contract uh to be implemented
in the new procurement
contract um we're
also
um we need to make sure that um the
committee will revised that we were
expecting the home situation to
worsen
um in the report it said that the use of
guest houses and hotels was expected to
continue to fall so again we would need
to monitor that and also what obviously
other processes and alternative process
have been brought into
account uh and it was agreed that a
briefing on the cabinet's current
approach and strategy towards housing
and homeless would be provided to
osc
um we're also expecting an information
sheet on complex needs as well um that
we're still waiting for which hopefully
will be part of that um um um the
changes Improvement to the procurement
tendering process that have will come
out um would be interested to see those
and again just clarification and
Confirmation be provided on the figures
and dates and their reports because
sometimes they were slightly
contradictory again um I could
understand the reasons why but again our
person scrutinies to make sure we've got
Clarity in our report so um yeah on the
whole it was uh supported by by the Comm
committee um felt it you know we needed
to help our residents particularly the
vulnerable um especially vulnerable in
this case uh and we also needed to make
sure um any form of antisocial Behavior
was also looked at as well uh and
monitored so and uh we uh did praise the
the head of Housing and customer
services for all the good of work she
was doing as well and she wasn't there
to hear it so I've said it in this
meeting there so thank you
councelor Co is any particular answers
to those questions that were raised by
overview and scrutiny I think mostly
it's covered by a yes
absolutely uh I coun no nobody else we
need a a second oh um sari W hings my
apologies sorry I know that um this is
this this matter is is at the heart for
for all counselors that we're all
concerned about this and I did wonder if
it might be wor worth organizing a
briefing for all counselors because
there seems to be some um lack of
understanding as to um the the need for
um people overseeing this type of
accommodation and the support that goes
into it and the difference between
homelessness and rough sleeping as well
that that seemed to come to come out a
little bit in O OC and I I did think it
didn't have to be a big a big training
session but maybe half an hour as to
what this is because you know we all see
in the you know about homelessness and
so forth and I do think that it might be
worth just giving all counselors a
briefing on on this because it's a key
piece of work that we all want to see
coming to the force that we've got
adequate provision with across the
district yeah we we did have one
training didn't we on on housing uh
which is now available on on record for
anybody that wasn't able to come but to
follow it up to make sure this critical
area is it all councilors particularly
in the new counselors are well versed
with the um the situation and the
terminology Etc might be a useful thing
to do um so if that's taken on board
then yes yes definitely and I think also
with you know the change environment
that may come out um I think having a
really quite practical session on who to
talk to about what and when would be
very very helpful for all counselors
especially the new ones do we have a
second then for Council grat is
seconding uh are you all happy with the
the report okay oh approved thank
you the next item is the home upgrade
Grant approval for entry to Pro to the
program and procurement of installation
Supply partner and again this comes down
to councelor calls thank you leader uh
yes this is essentially uh coming a
recommendation coming to us to engage
with a grant making um me mechanism
facility to support uh Energy Efficiency
uh thus improving housing conditions
especially in the current climate
um it will again be delegated to the
head of Housing and it is
essentially
covering a new form of Grant that's been
in place before um giving ourselves
permission to go ahead and apply for it
I think that can only really be a good
thing especially in view of the uh
Advantage we hope that it will deliver
and then the paper essentially describes
uh our expectations working with a
partner
within the framework of getting this
grant to deliver Energy Efficiency for
homes especially low-income
homes thank you councilor Co um do you
you move the
recommendations yeah uh does anybody
have any questions before we uh second
the the um the the
recommendations no
Council Rock do you want to say anything
just just just an observation um clearly
this is something that would fulfill
what we're trying to do in terms of
Energy Efficiency we're going to be
right behind it and uh we want to try
and go for it the one thing I think when
if if we're successful and we get
further down the line and we've got
local contractors doing this work we
must make sure that we protect those
local contractors that so we don't get
punitive terms that are not fulfilled
and there's been a poor track record of
these schemes elsewhere with um punitive
terms that people are on 180 days uh
payment terms and then I know from where
I've been involved before there's been
180 days beyond the term so people are
not been paid for years and they they've
gone out of business so I think that's
something to bear in mind when we get to
that stage I know we we're not at that
stage now so I fully support it and fact
I'm prepared to Second this
recommendation you you second there and
you've raised a a point about with
contractor capability and capacity which
is um something that we might have to
pick up later on but thank you for that
so that has been seconded and are you
all happy to approve that approved thank
you now we move on to the statford upon
uh Gateway draft man uh master plan
supplementary planning document uh and
this is Council
CA thanks chair I'm very pleased to be
able to bring this report to you and uh
I certainly would recommend that
everybody reads what I think is a very
very good document um which uh deals
with something which this council's been
concerned about for about 12 years this
is a very important site in Stratford um
and I'm delighted that we're now taking
the first positive step forward in terms
of um trying to come up with a scheme
for for eventual
implementation um the
SBD now covers the Arden Street Car Park
up the area which I think is a very
positive matter um because we're able to
deal with with car parking and
potentially with with uh with with with
Coach uh matters um all within the SBT
area which is very very good
um I would draw two areas where I have
uh slight reservations about one is
about train services for those of you
who are keen on on paragraph
4.37 um we don't ever have a direct
train service from Stratford to Houston
and we don't have one directly to New
Street in Birmingham either uh so that
that I'm sure that will be picked up by
um by uh our our our train spotting
friends uh going for forward um I also
have some personal um reservations about
coaches in Rother Market which I know is
also going to be quite controversial
however I think it's a very good
document it needs to go out to
consultation um we need to get views
back um and I would very much move the
recommendation so you've moved that
recommendation and and it is um it is uh
something that we need to emphasize that
this is a public consultation uh and
that we will look at the responses that
come forward uh do I have any other
comments if not do I have a seconder for
this counselor cuse and what what's the
view of everybody else are you happy to
approve it okay agreed that this goes
out to the public consultation and then
it will come back to us thank
you then we now move on to the um
adoption of the infrastructure funding
statement 2022 to 23 and this is
councelor coucher again thank you uh
this is a very important document and I
think it demonstrates the breadth of
what we're act what we're actively
involved in clearly um infrastructure is
one of the key concerns of this Council
going going forward um and this is
basically um the the sources of
infrastructure funding that we have
coming forward as set out here and it's
very important that we do monitor this
um on a on a fairly regular fly regular
basis um clearly we've got various
schemes um in relation to this some
which is being funded by other
authorities some being funded by 106 and
278 agreements some of it is s money um
some of it potentially could be um uh
provided as a result of the shared
Prosperity fund and the and the and the
rural fund as well so it's a very very
complex area the attitude that we have
taken this year is basically just to
take forward processes and procedures
that were put in place by the previous
administration uh to ensure that we have
continuity of of of of activity um so
the way in which this has been done the
way this has been brought forward is
very much consistent with that however
we will be reviewing um those protocols
particularly with Sil in over the over
the winter um in relation in preparation
for
2024 but I move the recommendation
chair does have we got anybody that
wants to make any any other comment um I
know we've got members of the of the
public here but uh no no comments that
you want to make uh councelor W
hoggins oh
okay I'm a little bit concerned about
I'm hoping that I've got the right um
Pages here I'm a little bit concerned if
we go to page
180 seems to be a number of
um errors on this as to those without
those Villages without a neighborhood
plan a particular note is L Compton
because they weren't the first in the
district to have a neighborhood
plan I believe that tredington also has
a neighborhood plan as does Morton moral
now unless I've read this incorrectly
these are the those without a
neighborhood plan therefore gaining only
15% of s
monies there are far more if you look on
page 181 there are far more um than than
those there listed that have got a
neighborhood
plan and I think that this is um making
this very difficult to read and also is
alarming because have um have those
villages with a neighborhood plan being
paid the right amount of s monies we've
done some checking um about this and um
I'm not intending to say anything
further but there are errors on this
document tyo definitely have a
neighborhood plan for example um could
those um those details be check to we we
will check on that was aware of that
situation okay yeah so those those
details will be um um um checked for you
because this is um we say we've um this
has been the the progress and the the
documentation that's uh has has been
used for a while but it does need to be
back checked okay thank you it's not
just the checking it's the fact that um
if these errors here have been
replicated in the payments then there is
um you know there's a great deal more
money due to some of these uh villages
and it's important because uh from
firsthand experience some of these are
considerable um schemes that have been
brought to the for and if if they if
they're due for payments then they need
to be made uh as quickly as POS it would
be useful to know I mean we we could be
talking I don't know whether this has
ever been raised in the past with the
previous administration but it would be
useful to know whether this has been
something that's been historic or not I
don't think this is do go coun Trump yes
I think this is the first time this has
come about I think from over scrutiny
point of view um I think is making sure
we've got the
processes in place and they robust
enough yes as an ex officer myself I
know mistakes happen and sometimes the
wrong figures are put in the wrong place
which is quite good for an accountant
but um but it's it's
certainly I think yeah the underlying
bis is that not the actual figures which
are important particularly in terms of
how much we spent at sent over in terms
of 15 and 25% it's making sure we've got
a robust process uh and it doesn't take
you know um we got enough resources to
do it as well thank you you you have our
assurance that that that that is that
detail is going to be double checked and
we will report back okay coun the chief
executive wants to come chairman thank
you for that and absolutely we will
check that the the point I was going to
make is this is actually a
recommendation to council and you're not
being asked to resolve upon it today and
therefore it should have been part A of
the agenda not Part B it does makes no
no difference as the recommendation
you're going to make or the decision
you're going to make but we will make
sure by the time it gets to Council on
the 16th of October that we've checked
that that thoroughly and if necessary a
supplementary shedule will be provided
thank you
chairman we have a recommendation um and
councilor coucher has already moved it
which is that um the infrastructure
funding statement as set out in appendix
one be adopted but this is a a
recommendation uh to council uh and if
there are any councelor Curtis you want
to come in at before we take the vote
yes thank you dud I um just to say that
when the final recommendations do come
towards to to Cabinet um I would expect
them to both support residents but also
support this Administration in meeting
its policy priorities simply that R
thank
you we did we have a seconder for that
um that recommendation that for this to
go to
council councilor Gest okay everybody
happy with that that we've um accepted
the the this that the items and the
projects that are in here are to go
forward to council okay thank you
moved uh and we move on to the shared
Prosperity fund SPF and the rural
England uh Prosperity fund
recommendations uh and we note that um
councelor ker has left the room and I
would share this item the report sets
out the outcome of the project selection
process that's been undertaken for the
year two shared Prosperity fund and the
year one of the rural England Prosperity
fund at Stratford District Council and
it is useful to know that there was a an
organization a whole group of people uh
that came together um to under the um
the the to look at and judge and make um
recommendations on this one I sat in on
it on it uh it was the local Prosperity
advisor group and um I I'd like to thank
them for their work they put in an awful
lot of work in looking at every single
bid that came forward and um making sure
that it it met the criteria that had
been
set it is um a several part fund um
there was some part of the fund for the
UK shared Prosperity fund last year this
is the second year and then there will
be a third year and and then the is the
rural Prosperity fund is a sec is a
separate item has anybody got any
particular questions that they want to
raise on the um the the paper before we
go to move the
recommendation M the public member the
public counselor
Carill who is a town counselor thank you
chair I am involved in this uh the oler
men shed aler Community shed which is
now for uh a Grant application and thank
you very much indeed for that um I'm
only here to answer any questions that
you may have on the scheme which I
consider extremely worthwhile uh however
obviously if you aren't aware of the
men's shed scheme then perhaps there got
any questions you'd like to ask me I'm
and here and available thank
you anybody got any questions on any of
the projects again this will I think
will go to council for um no this will
be approved by the cabinet uh today then
if there's any questions then uh our
Economic Development officer is at the
back if if anybody wants any questions
that's raised on any particular project
U but the projects all have been
scrutinized very very thoroughly by the
uh local Prosperity advisor group
councelor Kohl's sorry this isn't
directly relevant I just because you men
shed um do you take donations of tools
and equipment to use at this going no
it's not that sort of place this is a
doing place yes it's where things are um
for example it's all about Men's Health
both physical and mental and how that
quite often people men particularly
who've LED an active life retire and
they have very little and out to do and
the poor health outcomes that that come
from that the idea is that it's a space
a safe space to meet talk about those
issues that men tend not to talk about
terribly well and also make things which
is obviously something that men love
doing but I I just hasten to add that it
isn't just a men's share this is called
the AER Community shared and we do have
shared areas for example where some of
our very popular organizations like the
repair Cafe um very successful and we
have spin-off groups for example bike
repair and the sewing groups so in other
words it's a space that is I say again a
doing space as opposed to just a simple
meeting space
place thank you uh councilor W huggings
do you want to come in at the point yes
I'd like to thank um Mr Caro for coming
in today and speaking to us councelor
Caro from olster Council but um can I
ask please you know these considerable
sums of money that are being paid to
various individuals and organizations
what kind of checkups are we doing as a
council in order to ensure that they
that that that considerable resources is
being well utilized and also it would be
nice and I and I'm really glad that
we've heard from the olster community
shed today it would be really nice to
hear um some reports from these
organizations that we've supported as to
how they're getting on and the
difference that that th that that's been
that they they've they've made it could
be on the website it could be you know I
don't need it on a matrix I just and it
doesn't have just some sort of you know
I've managed to employ an additional
person for example or that that kind of
that kind of detail would be I think
will be really use and also useful for
our residents that they're seeing at
firsthand the difference that their
money is making to their to their
locality thank you um the deputy chief
executive can come in at this point yeah
thank you leader um anybody who's
awarded money under the scheme is um
asked to sign up to a sort of a contract
with sort of performance indicators and
Reporting mechanism to make sure that
they deliver what they've said otherwise
there's a requirement to sort of
potentially return some of the money to
us there's a system to monitor that we
should be getting to the stage now where
the year one projects are getting closer
to completion and I think there should
be some good news stories coming out of
that due to S of the delay in receiving
the money from the government some of
those are still sort of ongoing at the
moment but as and well we've got some
good news stories I think that's a very
good thing that we should be S sharing
on behalf of the council to show how the
funds have been used
wisely and it would might be useful to
uh look at the membership of the lpag
but it is quite wide the number of
people that are are on there
um wide range of expertise uh and it
meets um on at least three occasions a
year and looks thoroughly at not only
the projects that are coming up but also
looks you know at the projects that have
have come forward this is the second
year of it uh but it would be useful to
be able to uh celebrate um those those
um those projects that have been
successful it really would be a good
news story to to be able to do that uh
I'm happy to uh move the C
Curtis thank you leader um I'm just
looking at the um unders spends on both
of these and looking at paragraph 172
SDC recommended we explore options for
using the underspend I wonder if Mr
Buckland or Mr Perks would like to make
any comment on help because the last
thing we want to do is to see this money
going
back uh thank you councelor Curtis we're
looking at a couple of options with that
um the way the scheme is configured we
have to spend the money in accordance
with the interventions that we proposed
to government that we wanted to use the
money for um Mr won at the back is
currently sort of applying to the
government to sort of see what
flexibility we have with that about
using the money in other areas or
transferring it to next year's funding
and particularly in respect of the rural
fund we received fewer bids to that fund
than we'd hoped for so we've got some
proactive work going out to try and
attract some more sort of bids in year
particularly for capital investment in
rural businesses which we think there
there should be a demand for there was
some suggestion that perhaps the timing
of the scham coincided with sort of the
busy period of the Agricultural sort of
businesses and maybe that there' be an
opportunity to try and sort of get a bit
more out of that so we are looking at
options to make sure that we don't send
any money back that could be used by our
communities and and we are moving to the
recommendations uh I've I've you know
being able to celebrate the successful
projects actually would encourage others
in future so we do have the
recommendations I'm moving the
recommendation could I have a second to
that recommendation counselor Curtis are
you all in favor of those
recommendations okay then we move it and
thank you very much indeed thank you for
coming forward and putting your point of
view and the next item on the agenda is
again for councelor coucher who is now
uh in the room again after the last item
uh it is about the local visitor economy
economy partnership agreement for centry
and wara councelor
coucher thanks very much chair um we
have decided um that clearly we are
going to be part of the what's now
described as the elv for c c in warshire
um which is the The Right Move um and we
will be um asked to sign a partnership
agreement as as part of that and
recommendation is that we do so um there
are some budgetary implications of this
although they are not entirely clear at
this point in time um but uh we will
have um we'll have notice of that um uh
coming up in due course are you moving
that recommendation I am indeed okay
anybody got any particular questions to
raise in which case I will second that
uh recommendation can it go to the vote
please happy to accept it approved thank
you now we come to I issues arising from
overview and scrutiny that haven't been
moved up till now uh Council
Crump um yeah I think we can hopefully
be quite brief on this one um main
issues were around councelor Cole's
report that discussed and also about the
uh self build Reg
um again that we've discussed already um
yeah certainly a good session with
yourself and the deputy leader and I do
apologize again that I kept in going you
by first times rather than your uh deput
leader and leader at the meeting so
hopefully that was noted um I think what
we were Keen to look forward again is a
couple of things it was to do with um
hybrid working um we quoted examples of
of I think the audit and standards
meeting which was I think was 20 odd
minutes um the fact that Southtown
Council wouldn't cor it so they had to
cancel its meeting um so we were
wondering whether council could write to
government to see if there could be some
more flexibility in terms of of
Arrangements of meetings to encourage a
greater
participation um we also rais the
potential issue about paperless as much
as possible um lots of that
um I use this here but um with my other
hat on the county um almost pipus as
much as possible and with the use of
surface Pros rable Etc is is okay to do
so um and I know that one size does not
always fit all so there might be
Arrangements need to that but I think in
terms of our climate change climate
emergency it could be a lead we can
potentially take um there was a point of
clarification as well that the climate
he said the climate change panel reports
here it does but it reports indirectly
it comes through over in scrutiny then
then comes here as well um not pre
Precious on that and I think it's it
works well um so yeah not too much again
again the only other thing and this is
probably a the ccil the rock is um to
make sure that um we've got the
neighborhood plans the council um the
Paris and T Council has gone through
that and obviously they will potentially
need to be modified to take into account
the new safe local plan um we need to
make sure we're are engaging with in
terms and Parish councils and I know
that um our district councilors do go to
turn and Parish Council meetings and and
put out but you can't tell them if the
par paral 10 council meeting has been
canceled because they're in court
because so I think there's couple of
issues there um if we can potentially
support towns and Paris councils along
process because it is quite quite
complicated um it seems to be a lot of
planning based today so we're not
picking on Mr Kord honest or C the coach
yeah um yeah so uh um I think that this
there things we do need to look at but
um I it was it was a positive meeting I
think that um we do need to move forward
and the other issue was around
communication and I councelor rice if he
was here he'd be raising the issue and
again um about an engagement and then
the um contradiction between potentially
sending out a 60,000 home uh Leaf at one
of you and obviously the cost of that in
terms of climate and financial costs
including postage um compared to trying
to people who not internet or Internet
Savvy and again I think there's got to
be some one siiz if it's all we need to
work with our partners to make sure the
message goes out as well so um so it's
not just all planning John um uh there's
a bit of communication as well so um
lots of positive things we're
doing sometimes we don't tell our
members of the public that we're doing
these things I think we all need to do
better uh and particularly um
publicizing where I can access grants
and things like that as well so I think
yeah it was a good meeting and two half
hour so we're getting below the three
which is quite good uh and L lots of
scrutiny so thank you very
much is it on the overiew and scrutiny
specifically okay um yeah because um I
brought up something at the overview and
scrutiny as well which was about uh the
engagement of town and Parish councils
with tree planting
and uh I said there there's very little
evidence of it yet I think a letter has
gone out saying is there any land for
tree planting but I brought up the point
that 20 years ago Stratford District
Council ran a um a tree Warden scheme
successfully for getting on for 10 years
which um uh which um there there was an
officer um allocated from Street Scene
to administer it
and there was lots of training for tree
wardens and the tree wardens were
voluntary and attached to parish
councils and I was one of them and we
had lots of training from various people
in this room um and it gave a lot more
um information about what to do with
trees not tree pres preservation orders
and all sorts of other things as well
and how to plant trees all sorts of
things and um but there was a lot more
engagement in that and um I know that
the um council is short of resources but
um heart of England Forest is very good
at all that sort of thing and I know
they do come out to town councils and
give some advice but I wonder if if
there could be a more formal um
Arrangement that was um possibly U
arranged through he of England
Forest we did have art of England forest
in to give uh I can't remember which
organizer which committee it was to give
um a talk about uh I think it was
climate change committee about the work
they did um and um I'm sure that that's
something you know but there's also
Woodland trust and Wildlife trust and
they are on the um agenda to be invited
in certainly the wildlife trust is to be
invited into the climate change panel as
well but it's certainly something worth
worth worth considering um we'll take it
to the um the relevant officers and see
what um what what what could be done
about that okay is there any other
questions that um we've got Part D
cabinet committees there were none there
part e is unblock items um and for this
um unless a request is made and there
hasn't been any requests made at the be
at the beginning of the meeting for any
items to be discussed we go forward with
the and they're all on block which
covers the cabinet work program and the
statford on a market Forum uh and so
they're all accepted happy to accept
those on block
okay and then the um Part F is other
matters urgent business I don't think
there is any urgent business that I've
been notified of so that means that the